turning points okay so if you want a
band diagram for it okay I can get rid
of this done it's not gonna be one of
those overlapping ones you've got
stationary points which is like a family
all different kinds of points where the
derivative is equal to zero okay but
within that there's a subset right of
tiny points okay
and it's smaller there are some
stationed in points as you'll see in a
second which are not 20 points what is a
ten point what's the name suggests it's
okay sir so here I was increasing and
then the Apple turned around right
and it became decreasing okay so
therefore this is not just a stationary
point but also a turning point now
there's my sort of plain English
definition I said the stationary point
where to wire the x equals zero what
kind of technical do ydx definition
could you give to me that defines a
turning point what does it mean to be
attorney okay so that's what it's doing
how would we describe that in terms of
okay sure hit here's my definition which
is sort of that but a little bit
different okay a turning point exists
where dy/dx this is why I started off
with science right where dy/dx changes
sign before and after okay so in this
example my Apple right if I were to draw
on there what is the sign of the
derivative okay
well because this part here they're all
increasing right so be positive positive
positive positive positive okay and then
there's this point and then after that
the derivative the gradient countries
right so because dy/dx has changed sign
that's what makes that a stationary
point okay
now turning points are tricky of those
nation new points that's that's what I'm
sort of implying okay so first